le potager c'est souvent un souvenir
d'enfance un souvenir de vacances à la
campagne où on le retrouve dans toutes
les fermes dans les jardins des
papillons ou des villas votre foi il
permettait aux paysans de survivent
aujourd'hui encore les agriculteurs les
ruraux en général attendent de leur
potager l'essentiel de leur alimentation
par goût pour le sport
[Musique]
il rate
alors ça ce sont des légumes qui ont un
goût très particulier c'est naturel sans
pousser entièrement naturellement sans
engrais chimiques
c'est à nous en propre pour toi des
potagers aujourd'hui alors que la
culture intensive de type industriel
permet une abondance de légumes sur les
marchés toute l'année nous sommes allés
chercher une réponse à cette question
auchan comme à la ville pour les ruraux
comme pour les masses d'urbaniser le
jardin potager c'est d'abord un avantage
et puis un indispensable retour à la
nature
ils sont beaux c'est une réussite
ça a bien donné ici le potager dans la
ferme c'est votre domaine vous parvenez
à voir combien de kilos de pommes de
terre 300 kg dans l'année pour notre
jardin aux besoins personnels
150 kg de poireaux à peu près puis on a
eu des endives ou si cette année 100 kg
100 kg oui et puis maintenant je
commence à faire mon semis de printemps
voyez chou tout ce qui c'est sa salade
toute l'année oui toute l'année les
petits pois des petits pois j'ai fait
mon semi la de l'hiver alors je commence
à faire tous les semis de printemps
c'est important dans une ferme
pathologie c'est surtout qu'on sait ce
qu'on mange
oui tout est bon c'est frais et qu'est
ce que vous faites du surplus de votre
production
on l'a rarement sur plus on mange
vraiment ou par nous mêmes
keller j'ai un congélateur je mets des
haricots verts je fais tous mes tomates
pour faire me so ce que je mets au
congélateur
les asperges les asperges fait tout ça
[Musique]
on dit bien que le français est né
jardinier pour qui possède un coin de
terre cela se vérifie toujours il
habitait un immeuble de 16 étages à
paris à l'heure de la retraite ils se
sont retirés dans une petite ville et
ils ont découvert l'art et le plaisir
de plus steve et leurs jardins avoir
l'intention les avoir mais trop profonde
et petits pois et pourtant je préfère
les mettais pas si profondes
c'est ce qu'ils disent sur les paquets
de graines chaque rang sur les paquets
de graines et des sports en plus je dis
plus rien c'est toi le chef
allons-y gaiement pour vous la retraite
cela consiste aussi à cultiver son
jardin
oh bien sûr évidemment parce que c'est
agréable quoi on récolte des légumes on
vient chercher sur légumes du jardin on
les épluche la demi-heure après les
manches ce formidable quoi connaissance
avez vous des problèmes de la culture au
jour des connaissances plutôt
élémentaire quoi mes grands parents
étaient des paysans mon père a été aussi
jardiner aussi quand tu étais enfant
alors moi tout naturellement je suis
revenue à ça est-ce que vous parvenez à
vivre ici en autoconsommation 20 dans
l'ensemble oui je fais pratiquement tous
les légumes tous mes légumes surtout
j'en fais pas mal déjà on assez grande
quantité pour mettre en conserve ou au
congélateur vous voyez ce qui fait que
je pense tout l'hiver avec sa cote était
enfant qui repart toujours avec 2 est-ce
que ça ne finit pas par revenir cher
d'avoir un potager en investisseur en
achat de matériel et leurs hommes du
yorkshire nos surprises je vous aime
vous personnellement que j'ai bien du
mal à acheter un légume sur le marché
pour brûler toujours l'air triste
légumes allaient lâcher
toujours molles les fruits c'est pareil
je mens jamais 13 du marché
c'est manipuler la la c'est manipuler
une fois dans la pierre à hêvié nettoyer
l'huile au vinaigre
ça y est c'est fini ou une bonne soupe
bien fraîche battant quoi donc pour vous
le retour à la nature c'est aussi un peu
de bonheur
mais comment parler de potager à tous
ceux qui vivent dans les f3 et f4 des
villes nouvelles
cerné par des horizons de béton
jacqueline qui travaillent loin de son
domicile et subi trois heures de
transport par jour a appris qu'il
existait des jardins familiaux loué par
les communes elle a fait une demande et
obtenu un bout de terre pour 165 francs
par an l'occasion de vous aérer toute la
semaine dans les bureaux et à la maison
pour faire le ménage alors au moins
c'est vraiment une détente puis je
m'aère énormément et c'est tout de même
de certains rappeurs oui c'est un de ses
terrains par le fait que ça me permet de
manger des légumes frais du jardin et
légumes que je ne serais peut-être pas
toujours parce qu'ils sont quand même
assez cher et puis j'ai la chance de
pouvoir manger des haricots verts par
exemple que j'ai fait un bep coup
l'année dernière au moment où guarico
centre à 550 aussi se comprendre que
l'eau dans cette maison vous habitez
dans cette résidence vous n'avez guère
de rapport avec les voisins non parce
que tout le monde travaille on rentre et
on se voit vous restez dire porte tandis
qu'ici au jardin et bien on se parle on
se donne des conseils on se connaît
mieux
enfin ça permet vraiment des rapports
zulma venir nous
c'est ainsi que l'on parvient à
retrouver une certaine qualité de la vie
[Musique]
c'est votre dernière récolte de choux de
bruxelles
ah oui vraiment c'est la dernière
récolte est ce que je cueille la
voyez-vous ce sont des andes floral de
choux de bruxelles
elle constitue un extrêmement délicat
j'appelle ça l'aspergent du pauvre voyez
vous les faites cuire comme ceci est à
l'eau et vous les mangez à la
vinaigrette
il n'ya denver du pardon rien de perdu
et rien n'est perdu rien de perdu donc
les rangs de bruxelles vont disparaître
zèle et les arrachant ils vont
disparaître une fois j'aurais fait ma
cueillette
je vais les arracher portez tous à la
fumière parce que ça n'est pas perdu et
ça constitue un excellent congrès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr pour réussir se récoltent le
jardinier amateur a besoin de s'informer
de ce qu'il faut planter sur quelle
terre à quel moment il faut aimer la
nature avoir le ou de l'observation
l'esprit curieux des revues spécialisées
apporte des informations précises
actuellement les potagers demande tous
vos soins alors nous sommes allés
demander conseil à un expert en la
matière parmi les travaux d'avril en
priorité ameublir le sol ameublir le sol
mais sans retourner la terre simplement
en la soulevant que de cette façon
premièrement vous enfoncez la bêche
légèrement à l' oblique
deuxièmement vous la puce est devant
vous de la main gauche pendant que de la
droite vous prenez une poignée de
formules d'engrais que vous jetez entre
le faire de labège et la terre
troisièmement où vous reculez un peu et
vous soulevez la terre et vous
recommencez à côté 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1
de droit qu'est ce que c'est que cet
engrais longrais c'est une composition
de compost 400 grammes à 500 g de
compost au mètre carré enrichi d'un
engrais 6 9 12 qu'on trouve facilement
dans le commerce à la dose de 100 à 150
grammes au mètre carré
[Musique]
il ne reste plus qu à greffer la terre à
seule fin de légaliser de l'affiner sur
cette terre légère on s'aimera des
légumes à la volée comme la mâche leur a
dit le cerfeuil ou bien en ligne comme
pour ce rang de carotte pour éviter les
parasites insecticides et ensuite tasser
la terre
on peut ainsi se met en ligne haricots
et petits pois
et
que peut-on planté et bien au mois
d'avril peu de plantation en ce moment
les dernières pommes de terre et les
premières salades pour planter les
pommes de terre
je fais un trou un autre trou je fais
tous les trous dans ma ligne de
plantation ensuite je place la pomme de
terre dans le trou et je n'ai plus qu'à
griffé la surface du sol pour en tirer
mes pommes de terre dans ce périmètre
vous ne parvenez à faire de la culture
intensive
ah oui c'est absolument nécessaire dans
un petit jardin de faire de la culture
intensive
la culture intensive ça constitue dans
un maximum de rendement dans la plus
petite surface toute l'année vous avez
dans votre jardin
quelques culs exactement exactement en
hiver il ya des cultures en hiver mon
jardin rapporte et c'est ça l'important
est un fils est là bas pourquoi le filet
la basse et tour la culture des
cornichons le cornichon grimpe sur le
filet si bien qu'il ne tient pas de
surface au sol alors sur une surface
absolument réduite
j'ai une grosse production de cornichons
et au pied des cornichons je peux faire
des salades chez salah toute l'année en
ce moment ce sont des salades d'hiver
vous aviez une terre vous avez votre
jardin mais vous vouliez un jardin
potager
oui je voulais un jardin potager parce
que le potager sa ses titres de noblesse
un potager c'est décoratif eux
l'alignement des légumes c'est quelque
chose de très agréable à voir et puis
vous pouvez le marié avec des fleurs
vivaces avec des rosiers et d art brut
est également un jardin potager un
refuge et une joie qui fait rimer nature
et culture saveurs et fraîcheur
[Musique]